thank you so much
jason um this was really amazing to have
you um i'm joining
us tonight um from my home just because
of the heightened state of things
in the pandemic but thank you for
joining us live from the interval
tonight so that you can answer some of
the questions that are coming in from
our stream thank you so much for being
here
happy to be here great awesome um well i
hope you enjoyed uh seeing the version
of your talk i'd love to just get into
some of the questions that that i had
you know i think one of the possibly the
most provocative statement that you have
in here
um is this idea of the queer vaccine
which you know obviously vaccines
couldn't be more on the forefront of all
of our minds
at the moment but i don't think that's
the one that people were thinking of
uh being being used and that and you
know obviously how provocative that is
from a eugenic standpoint
so i'd love for you to just kind of
unpack that a little bit more as to
you know i think what you were trying to
say is that there are people in places
in the world that are so
persecuted that it could actually help
suffering
for those people and and that you can't
take it off the table for people that
might be killed because of their
their queerness pretty much i mean every
every year
our understanding of of the of the
genetics of homosexuality of sexuality
in general
um our understanding of of genetic
technologies in general increases
and every every year every two years we
see
the results of a giant massive study
looking at trying to identify the gay
gene and
we're getting closer to the point where
we haven't identified the gay gene
yet we think it may be multiple genes um
but it's that
it's that i we hint at it in the video
it's this idea that
um there could be a mechanism by which
we never have to identify the gay gene
but we can identify what affects that
gene um
for example uh every
for every male fetus that was in a womb
before the next one uh that that next
fetus has a 33
chance greater chance of being born gay
um so that we know there's something
about the hormonal
uh changes and positioning and balance
in the womb
um that can if that affects sexuality uh
so my concern
i mean this is a great this is a wild
card uh you know low probability but
very high impact um my is that
we don't need to spend fifty thousand
dollars to edit out the gay gene
fetus by fetus uh but we could actually
just we could work around that never
identify the
the gene itself but just prevent it from
activating um if
what if that was a dollar a day
supplement uh for a pregnant person
um you know to have a to reduce the
chance of having
a queer kid by 50 or greater um
i mean that was one of the first putting
all those that to injury together was
one of the first times i
felt i felt i felt kinship with my
community
i felt it was it was i felt a bit of
kind of existential uh existential
communal
kinship really like we could we could go
extinct
uh what is there about i mean there have
been evolutionary biology theories about
why homosexuality
for forever that we help raise the kids
that we are we are supplemental parents
that we
um mediate we mediate the tribe
um but what if it would just what if it
were to disappear
what if we had the ability to make it
disappear um
i think there's a lot of cr and this is
the genesis of the research i think
there's a lot of queerness that's worth
saving
indeed and i think to your point i mean
when
sonograms became available in um in
certain countries and regions that
that you know basically um kind of exalt
male children um we've seen the the
female
birth rate fall through the floor um and
so you know there's there's already
kind of these levels of using technology
for a eugenic or a
societal kind of desire um and so
you certainly could imagine in places
where countries
that are so violent and uh marginalized
for
um for queerness that those parents may
choose to not have a queer child for
sure
and and to the way you frame the
question would
is preventing a a queer child from being
born in one of those conservative places
is that actually an act of compassion
um from actually from i mean i can't i
can't dismiss that possibility
right and you can imagine parents making
it from that point that place in their
heart
um not from you know obviously from a
place of
i think you know misunderstanding of
what it is but also but truly
understanding how difficult that kid's
life is going to be in their culture
that's why it's one of the even even
even in the most developed progressive
places it's one of the first
uh many parent many ask any queer person
and their parents one of their first
reactions will be when you come out
will be i just want you to i don't want
you to have a hard life
um and that's that's that's such a
universal reaction that parents have
upon coming out
um it can only be when when you have the
potential to prevent that
in a place where that life would be so
tough
that's a that's a that's going to be a
tough bioethical
crossroads to be that that we're facing
no and i think we're i mean we're going
to be facing this for
in all kinds of parts of genetic
engineering and we are you know as i
said there's already ways that we're
finding it out for gender itself
um i think you know but you know and
we're already you know when you know my
daughter was born they gave us all these
host of tests that we could
test for to decide if we wanted to have
a kid of that had various diseases
um and so again from the compassion of
the parents position
they may want to choose to not have that
child um
and it's a it's but it it also kind of
it takes it takes this whole
realm of um of i think
um a variation out of the human
experience too which is i think you know
if
all the kids were these blonde blue eyed
perfect you know eugenic
you know kids um that all had the same
gender preference and
and non-queerness then you know i don't
think that's the world that we actually
want to live in truly
yeah i agree no i think to that point i
i think um you know and we're seeing now
a much more acceptance at least in
certain
uh in certain cultures of queerness you
know things shows like queer eye having
such a huge
thing and rupaul's drag race being you
know this huge um
you know kind of success and emmy award
reward winning thing that
that there's clearly a huge acceptance
at least in certain cultures
that queerness and otherness bring so
much to our culture
that that they that these marginalized
groups
um can help our culture in so many ways
and i'm wondering what your thoughts are
and why why is it that the marginalized
groups can bring us so much creativity
and so much
um so much kind of fabulousness to her
to our culture
what is it about the marginalization
well as
as we hit in the in the video i think
there's when when you choose to come out
when you choose to life
live the life of that is you know let's
say queerness is five to ten percent of
the population right
um you are you are living your life
against the ninety percent of that
mainstream
um and it's a double-edged sword you are
you no longer have the autopilot
um that many people have um that were
the obvious
next decisions made for you do i well
yes i naturally get married
you naturally have kids uh but you also
have so much more freedom
uh to to chart your own path and i think
to try your own path
to explore ideas
and arrangements and these these spaces
between binaries that we talked about
um that would you when you're living
when you're living in the margins i mean
the mar the margins are
really the the foundry of creativity the
foundry of the future
um and i think that's i think a queer
life just lends itself
lends itself naturally to greater
consideration
greater uh awareness of the choices that
we're making
um and and also greater experimentation
you know and i think you know uh our
previous speaker dr lonnie brooks who
was talking
about afrofutures as well as afro career
features i think one of the things that
he pointed out that was really
eye-opening for me
was this this notion that um that
that black people have have had to be
futurist because their marginalized
present was so
so difficult that in a way they had to
project a better future for themselves
in order to
to kind of have a present that they
could live with and um i'm wondering is
do you feel as though that's a similar
thing for queer populations
i do actually i i have a i believe this
is
a saying of mine but that queer people
actually
queer people make some of the best
futurists because for most of our lives
we've had to hope that tomorrow that
tomorrow will be better for us than
today
um that we will be more respected more
welcome more accepted
in the world of tomorrow the world of
next week in the world of next year
and then we happen today and we know yes
we're
i'm losing my trajectory here but yes
we're making progress
um but it is it is scattershot progress
we are
you know often going two steps forward
one step back um we're not there yet
yeah and and going back to some of the
new technologies i think you know some
of the new technologies that may be
coming in genetics
may allow you know you you said that you
know that um some queer parents are seen
as this extra set of parents
um but um you know i think what's coming
um very obviously is that
um there's already technologies where
two people of the same gender can
effectively generate
a offspring or even you can generate
offspring based on only a single
person's
genetic material coming so do you think
that's going to change some of the
outlooks and the way
the ways we parent and the way we think
about parenting
i think it will and and what excites me
is that we
that queer people may actually be able
to uh perpetuate ourselves
um no longer that no longer being this
this this artifact or this this
rare mutation uh within the heterosexual
population within heterosexual
reproduction but that we could
uh potentially perpetuate queerness
ourselves there's a
there's a fascinating study recently um
that
uh children i believe children or
daughters
of lesbian parents are more likely to be
have
to have had same sex experimentation uh
and that's the
the theory the the the why is still up
for grabs of course
um but something that being raised by
queer parents creates
creates more of a space for for
for this experimentation for for
choosing choosing choosing your own for
following your own path following your
own preferences
uh and deciding what's right for you
which is
is really exciting well certainly i mean
some of the statistics you're showing
between gen z
and jen um you know the current
generation millennial generations are
the last chance
gen z and uh the millennial generation
that there's the acceptance seems to
also be allowing for so many more people
to identify
um in a in a really profound way i mean
we're not
you're close we're crossing the 50 line
of basically effectively gender
for um for people that that feel free to
identify as
as non-binary and part of it part of
that has been the terms so
i think as i understand that a lot of
the young people have
almost an allergic reaction to the terms
to the
to the first generation of terms lesbian
gay bisexual
transgender um as as as
the questions they're asked are they are
you are you gender fluid are you
uh have you are you not exclusively
heterosexual
uh as we talk more about these in
between categories and you you don't
have to fit into one
distinct category or bucket with a with
a 50-year past 50-year legacy
and making a huge declaration but just
be just be fluent to be open
that's when we're seeing these numbers
really climb
um from from the five percent that may
be gay
um in older generations to the
50 who are identified as not
so gender fluid or as not exclusively a
heterosexual
got all the way down to jet sea so it's
it's
so language is a part of it but also but
really just an understanding of this
of of spectrums and fluidity away from
the categories from first generation
we're certainly
we are at least in third
fourth generation of of lgbt
culture and life and activism now and
it's it's
it's i can't wait to see where it goes
right well i want to come back to that a
little bit i also have a few questions
coming in and
the first one from kevin kelly is
organizing our questions um and kind of
to this point of
do do you think science should guide
what we consider
queer or or should we should we let that
be a societal and a self
or a self um expression
is that should be the only thing that we
rely upon
i i think i mean queer is square is such
a moving target
um i mean queer almost queer almost
always needs something
to exist in opposition against um
uh i mean you know queer is um
how do i put it um i mean queer needs a
queer really does need to be
transgressive
um against against a prevailing system i
think i think that what is
the notion of what is queer will change
over time
um and i i
i think you know a identifying
identifying
the the gay gene identifying you know a
distinct
biology uh distinctive marker of
homosexual of
queerness over homosexuality um does not
necessarily
confer um confirm all these traits
and this is one thing that one nuance
that hasn't come up yet
is that queer is not queer is not
necessarily gay
um i mean there are queerness and
the the lgbt lgbt uh
is different than the q in many respects
um that
queerness is queerness is a is a form of
fluid homosexuality that that really
exists
i think in um in
active active conversation and active
um opposition to a lot of mainstreams
and these are these are some of the
traits that i was meaning to identify
um we have that quickly these these
acquiring not every uh lgbt person
can queer the future in the way that
someone who is truly who truly
identifies and embodies
queerness uh can so i think that's
that's an important distinction is
really isolating what is what is
queerness what is it now what
what has it been um and can we
can we keep that kind of this
non-assimilationist
identity can can we keep that coming
here we preserve that going forward
well that's interesting and i think you
know how this identity has kind of come
out and
been more accepted and you mentioned
things like the cafeteria and stonewall
riots which
um and and really how that it came from
the black
trans community that that really threw
the first bricks in the windows
literally of this of this fight um but i
i also feel as though to a certain
extent they kind of got left behind in
the movement and they're
we're just now starting to see them
coming forward
um in the conversation much more than i
think um you know let's say white gay
men
um and even you know white lesbian women
have
have been able to be accepted and i'm
not sure is that because
they could kind of pass in culture way
more than obviously
an a kind of an out black tray trans uh
woman or man i mean i think
you know we have to look back at it look
back at intersectionality which we
talked about
um the intersection of racism homophobia
transphobia
um you know the a a a
a transgender person of color um you
know
female female center person of color
um has a much has many many more
um uh you know against against
the mainstream expectation going going
for her
um and so yeah i think i think
look at look at the student
intersectional lens um
and those stats about poverty about
hunger that we that we pulled up
for a lot of those stats you know
between um they
though those stats don't really tell
tell the entire picture between
uh uh let's say gay white men
and straight white men um you know those
disparities are actually not
um you know whiteness is a lot of
privilege
um but if you look at you know the
you know what percentage of of of
of black black queer or black trans
people live in poverty
then those numbers get so much higher
those that we're talking a third
or higher people live in poverty live in
hunger
so we're just we really need to unmap
and understand
the nuances within our community well i
think to that point you know we have a
question here from
uh from nick from youtube feed um
you mentioned you know that the kind of
percentages of families that are
more accepting and less accepting at
this point luckily it seems to be on
largely on at least in american
culture on a good trajectory but what
about the research into the ones
that they kind of the 35 percent who
live in families that are unaccepting
but managed to stay
accepting like how how are we how are we
finding ways to support
those kids and how are they finding
support themselves
yeah i mean something like uh a thor i i
want to say i mean butcher the numbers
here but a third
up to 40 percent of homeless
teens or young adults are lgbt
um versus what being 10 of them 10
roughly of the population so this is
this is a real phenomenon
and luckily there are there are a lot of
groups that are focusing on
um you know queer kids queer kids queer
teens
or young adults who have been rejected
who are living on the streets
uh and trying to trying to specifically
solve
the the multiple intersecting problems
that they face
uh trying to get back on their feet
without family resources
i mean that's um the idea of the idea of
the chosen family
is so important to queer communities
right uh since so many
parents so many so many parents my
families are are rejecting
to some degree right whether it's don't
bring your partner home for christmas
um to don't ever don't ever come to my
house again
that the idea of the the notion of the
chosen family which is starting to
spread from
one of those innovations that sorry i
think starting queer culture and is
and is you know as has such benefit and
value that other people are
are adopting it um that the chosen
families is really important
is one of our survival adaptations and i
think survival
survival under many conditions is one
thing queerness
excels at i said uh we had one
clarification question that i'd like to
get from you is um
is what is what is a chosen family i
don't think everyone is understanding
that term
sure uh chosen family is so uh
parents you come out to your parents um
often
depending on where you live where your
parent how your parents were raised
is religion a part of the of the family
parents are often very rejecting
uh i know i every every lgbtq person
knows someone whose
family has essentially shunned them has
said do not
you are not welcome here they may be
talk once a decade
um a chosen family is you know you
you move away from it's often rural
rural to big city
um and these and chosen family are it's
the people that
are your new family it's the people that
are they're
a hybrid of their their their friends
they're former lovers
um they're they're the people that you
that you
whose shoulders you cry on um that you
you know talk to that that know your
life story
uh it's it's it's friendship plus really
um it's and think of it think of it as a
um who would you invite to thanksgiving
if if
if not for your own family uh i think
it's one
thanks thanksgiving is often where
chosen family really manifests
who would be who would be around who
would be around that very queer table
um right well
um i want to thank you very much for
this work and for giving this talk we're
coming across the top of the hour but
i'd love to give you a chance to
maybe say a little bit about either
where you're going with this work and or
what your
your next work is i know you work you've
been affiliated with the institute for
the future and they've been
uh they've been supporting this work to
some level but i'd love to hear kind of
where
what's your ecosystem of this work and
and where do you see it going next
oh i i want to keep pursuing this quite
honestly this is um
i mean i i really as i mentioned at the
very top of the video i mean i have been
i've been a futurist for 20 years i
have been uh basically out for about 20
years
uh and i'm finally feeling i'm finally
feeling those those converge
um i i want to explore both both queer
foresight so i'm really starting to
understand what are the forces
what are the future forces that will
disproportionately disrupt
the lives of lgbt people um i mean we're
talking we're talking automation
i think we'll disproportionately disrupt
um
you know these natural natural resource
depletion
uh will disproportionately disrupt
poverty hunger
um and then and so that we can begin to
future proof
future future proof my community future
proof um
us as a as a subculture um but then also
to explore
really to explore this querying as a as
a
as a tool querying as a mindset i mean
i'm going to get
i i as much as there may be some trouble
brewing in the
in the uh in the comments right now i'm
going to get in trouble for
even implying that queerness could be um
could be it into into a toolkit or a
utility
uh i think that but i i actually think
there's
so much there's a lot that queerness has
to struggle uh to struggle through
through pain through violence through
death has
mastered um and that i think needs to be
shared
and can help a lot of other people going
forward
so uh i think queer futures
in short i think is you know hopefully
that is
hopefully that carries me through uh as
a futurist
next well i'm i'm reminded when you say
that that um you know one of my favorite
principles of longevity uh
which was kind of coined around the
discovery of the bristlecone pine tree
the longest lived single species was
that adversity breeds longevity and that
things that live in the most difficult
environments are often the most
long-lived and we see this i think with
institutions
cultures um biology and and i'm hoping
that at least
through some of the adversity some good
things are going to be coming out of it
and thank you very much for joining us
um and
look forward to hearing more of your
work in the future
thank you thank you very much for
hosting me thank you and i want to thank
you our audience for joining us um the
recording of this will be up in
perpetuity
um and um and i hope for that you can
join us for some of our future talks we
have some amazing things planned for the
rest of 2021 which i'm hoping
will even bring us back to some
in-person
events at some point in the future so
thank you very much